candace owens is the host of candace and
we are always happy to have her on the
show kenneth owens thanks so much
for coming on saying who benefits i i
mean i just i used to think
that all of these arrangements were you
know american
guild that helped the countries from
which
these immigrants were coming now i think
el salvador and guatemala don't benefit
from this the u.s certainly doesn't
benefit from it so who is the
beneficiary here exactly
yeah absolutely the politicians that
want to get them in so that they can
change the demographics and get votes
and actually brought something that's
very important i actually interviewed
about a month and a half ago
in illegal immigrants actually on a path
to citizenship now thanks to marriage
and they were very honest with me and
they said that during this journey and
they particularly came from guatemala
that it was more harrowing to go through
mexico because the mexico police kept
trying to stop
the flow of illegal immigration and once
you get to america it's essentially a
finish line
because it's so organized and it's so
systemic so even though
this individual entered in through
california
as soon as you get into america an suv
is waiting she told me it took her to
a a location a house basically a safe
house and then
a bunch of americans come and transport
the illegal immigrants to various states
so i just want to say this she entered
in through california
and then 150 of them were broken up into
three states those three states were
texas tennessee
and virginia she went to virginia and
her friends went to
texas her friends went to texas and
tennessee that's a fascinating crucial
piece of this
now she entered this country 10 years
ago right uh since then virginia has
gone blue
we know that the biden administration is
having planes
enter in chattanooga that's made the
news a couple of weeks ago filled with
illegal immigrants in the middle of the
night
what's really going on here this didn't
just begin when biden and kamala got
into office this has been going on for a
very long time i believe a very long
time
and when trump got into office and
started talking about stopping the flow
they really got upset and they got very
angry because there has been something
that has been going on in terms of
trafficking over the border
to change demographics of his country
for a long time it is not a conspiracy
theory
it is the truth and i am so happy that
you're talking about it because at the
end of the day we know that kamala
harris are not they're not concerned
about
fixing the crisis they're concerned
about accelerating a plan
a plan that went into motion a very long
time ago and americans need to wake up
into it because you are correct
it is an invasion and there's nothing
truer than what you
just said and it has its roots and
political calculations nothing to do
with human rights or racial diversity or
ending sexism or any of that that's all
a diversion this is about changing the
political balance of the country it's
been going on a long time
and they get hysterical because it's
absolutely true
and in their lucid moments they brag
about i mean they don't hide this do
they
no they don't and you're right they get
hysterical because they don't want
people to listen to what we're talking
about
you know i'm a black american i'm not
sitting here trying to have this
discussion because
i don't want more brown people in this
country i don't care about brown people
coming in this country in fact tucker
if you want more brown people in this
country why don't we get more illegal
immigrants from africa i think they
represent about only two percent
of the immigrants that are coming into
this country this is not about brown
people or fear of having brown people
this is about
we not wanting our system to be crippled
by illegal immigration when we know that
at the end of it all they want to do
is to get a ton of them in here and then
to say make an application and a case
that for all of them to receive green
cards which is what we saw
this week in the supreme court which i'm
glad they shot down that effort to try
to legalize
400 000 illegal immigrants that are in
this country right now
and and this is what's actually
happening the democrats are after
changing demographics that they can
guarantee themselves power
because their policies no longer work
and inner cities are being corrupted
and what again what is so particularly
interesting to me is that they're being
taken
into what is normally a conservative
zone a conservative state that is
interesting to me that's exactly right
tennessee texas virginia wake up greg
abbott because it's happening
i appreciate candace owens you're coming
on tonight and how lucid your
explanation was thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else